hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video we're going to talk about is
how to work with finite differences to
determine whether a sequence is linear
quadratic or cubic okay or none of those
okay and so what we're gonna do is
sometimes when you're studying sequences
in series in your class you'll get a
difficult one where it's it's not
arithmetic where you're adding the same
thing each time it's not geometric where
you're multiplying by the same thing
each time so students can will be
confused it falls into that neither
category I just want to show you how you
can approach this to see if it's maybe a
quadratic and cubic or linear type of a
sequence so let's look at some examples
and I'll show you what I mean so if you
look at the sequence here it's probably
obvious to you that you know when you
subtract okay 5 minus 3 you're getting
to 7 minus 5 you're getting to 9 minus 7
you're getting to okay we keep getting
two each time we take the term minus the
term before at the previous term and
this is what's called a first-order
difference and when it's a first-order
difference and you're getting that same
number that means it's a first-degree
equation okay so X to the first so if we
wanted to find an equation we could
think of the equation of a line like y
equals MX plus B all we would need to do
is take two points like say for example
this is our first term and this is our
second term so we could think of this as
like 1 comma 3 okay and 2 comma 5 and we
can use these two points to find the
equation of a line and we can get our
form of the first sequence doing that ok
let's look at another example this one
here we're gonna go ahead and subtract
again so if I take the right turn minus
the left term okay or the term minus the
term before it 6 minus negative 1 is 725
minus 6 is 1962 minus 25 is let's see 37
right and 123 minus 62 is let's see 61
right okay now if we subtract again
because notice we don't have the same
quantity this is the first order
difference we're gonna subtract again 19
minus 7 is 12 37 minus 19 is 18
and 61 - 37 is 24 still we don't have
the same quantity right when we
subtracted the second time this is a
second order difference we're going to
subtract a third time et - 12 is 6 24
minus 18 is 6 and if you know if we keep
going we should continue to get that
same quantity but we wouldn't need to
have more terms here to verify that ok
so this looks like it's a cubic ok
sequence and if we wanted to find the
formula we could write a system of
equations using this general formula for
a cubic y equals ax cubed + BX squared
plus CX Plus D you could also use the
cubic regression feature on your
graphing calculator or your scientific
calculator what you would do is you
would think of this as term 1 so it'd be
like 1 comma negative 1 second term is 6
so this would be like 2 6 325 and 462
okay and so if you have you know four
points you can write four equations and
you can solve for the four variables a B
C and D okay now another way to do this
problem just to show you is that
sometimes what's helpful for students is
you know if you have maybe you know an
other thought that this might be a cubic
what you could do is you could like
underneath each of the terms you can
think of like I'll show you what I mean
here let me just write this 123 you can
think of this as like let's say like for
example you say well hmmm let's see 1
cubed is 1 2 cubed is a 3 cubed is 21 4
cubed is 64 and 5 cubed is 125 and then
you might notice you say well it looks
like I'm just subtracting 2 each time so
you'll be able to figure it out it's
okay n cubed minus 2 and there's your
formula so a lot of times the ones that
you're working with in your class they
might just be slightly removed from you
know a sequence of consecutive cubes
okay or squares okay so but you can
either way you can either do it this way
by writing a system of equations or
maybe see if it's you know just to like
a little bit removed from you know
sequence of cubes or squares last one
here we're going to subtract so 5 minus
2 is 3 10 minus 5 is 5 17 minus 10 is 7
okay
should have put a few more terms here
but 5 minus 3 is 2 7 minus 5 is 2 now I
notice we subtracted once twice it looks
like we're getting the same number each
time so that tells us it's a second
degree equation a quadratic and again we
could write a system of equations solve
for a B and C and that's our quadratic
equation that models the sequence you
would just again use the points 1 comma
2 2 comma 5 3 comma 10 and you would
have three equations you'd be able to
solve for the three variables a B and C
so I hope you're enjoying these videos
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and I look forward to
seeing you in some of the future videos
I'll talk to you soon